uh what do you got going on right now
musically obviously you're on tour you
got your you got records out but like
what's coming up next I'm about to drop
a single mm-hmm dropping down on the
17th so I'm excited about that I have a
project coming and like different
features throughout the year a whole
bunch of stuff
my for you uh when you put a project
together
like how do you decide like what makes
the I'm sure you're gonna have a bunch
of songs to choose from yeah how do you
decide what makes the album it's just
really the vibe that I'm adding life at
that moment because it's like
the way I'm me doing music I've had like
different areas where I do different
stuff so like wherever I'm at mentally
physically out at this where I go which
Eris
have you been in so far
um I was in my real cocky area in the
beginning just like I'm the I could
rap like you know what I'm saying
thinking like I gotta work hard I'm cute
I could do all that everything I'm like
no like hard work be telling every
time so of course then I started getting
my mature start being more like
technical my lyrics and stuff like they
really started like pushing myself more
and then I got to where I got into my
emotions like letting people see
different sides being vulnerable yeah
that's important yeah because that's
what people relate to mm-hmm but you
could catch like a hit and then
if people don't feel like you know
that's why I think what happened with
glow was like she started doing
interviews people were like oh this
she's amazing yeah I just like her yeah
I'm cool as yeah she's super cool
yeah yeah what's it like torn with her
is it like a Vibe like yeah she's a fun
time yeah like everybody always is high
positive energy she loves that wine
teleport wine it gets you up she
she did my club in Arizona and they put
that on the rider and I'm like guys I
don't know where to get this
11 o'clock at night
I know it's like 6.99 a bottle it's not
the product I'll give you guys 10
bottles of the show yeah
that's the jump right there are you a
Teleport fan I am okay I am that's a
Memphis or not I don't know I feel
like there's some glow she really
put me on today she put you under the
wine they had a wine is a Vibe yeah I
like it sometimes yeah it's heavy yeah